so you've been at this for quite a while
um and one of the things i always love
to ask people like you who are
world-class creatives
is how the heck you got started because
i feel like getting started in
in your field is like the hardest thing
in the world you know
like like you you grow because yeah like
you you go to the local high school
yeah um you know in your case i think
you attended nyu for a minute and then
dropped out
uh to pursue comedy uh i i wanna say
yeah i mean being latin back then and
being wanting to be an actor
was was not the most successful looking
choice
because you know they just didn't cast
us they didn't cast us no matter what we
always cast it out you know
uh never made it you know like all my
white friends that were at nyu studying
acting were going to like
five editions a day i was going to one
every five months
so i saw i saw i saw you you must have
felt that so acutely because you're on
this program
and you're like wait a minute like you
know that like there just aren't as many
roles that's fascinating that's crazy
yeah and i was able to see it firsthand
i was going wow why
why don't i have the same options i
study like them i have the same grades
i studied with better acting teachers
than they did i say with herbert
berghoff and lee strasburg why don't i
have the same opportunities because of
the way i look in my name
and uh that came you know became a
realization really fast and then i knew
you know i started to learn that wow
this is this is going to be very
difficult and i i need to find
other ways to to stay you know sane and
stay creative so i started writing
because that's one place nobody could
stop me you know nobody could tell me no
or or excluding so the stuff you started
writing initially was it
comedy was it jokes like what did you
say about writing yeah you know i was
writing jokes in high school
because i had a very competitive comedy
table at lunch and you couldn't sit at
the table unless you had
the best jokes and if you didn't have
the day before you weren't allowed to
sit at the table
so is matt competitive so i used to have
to write jokes to be able to win because
you can't just
you know be improvised and you're not
going to come up with the top joke
so yes i started writing then and then
by the time i graduated college i
started
uh writing uh sort of a character
sketches
you know uh i was doing improv at first
amendment which was this big
downtown improv comedy group that was
huge you know bruce willis went there
rob williams would come there and
you know and and a lot of communities
would come there and steal jokes too
that was a real thing i learned too i
mean some of your jokes they probably
couldn't steal it because it wouldn't
make sense for them because i'm sure
some of them had to do with being latino
people people are clever though
comedians except they don't know how to
flip a joke
don't make it fit so you're scrapping
and clawing for a while
in the new york comedy scene like when
did you feel like okay
like this is gonna work you know like
i'm gonna make it
uh where you started having like uh some
success and getting cast in various
roles like
what what would you consider your own
breakout
my breakthrough moment uh when
everything
just fell into place was when i did my
first one-man show called mamamoth in
1990
and uh you know they didn't really
believe in my show they kind of believed
in my show
because i was in the hallway of the
theater i wasn't even in the theater i
was in the hallway of the theater
with a makeshift platform 70 fold up
seats
that they would pick up at eight o'clock
when the real show started
and and i had to be god you know all my
audience had to be cleared out
but you know the reviews came in and
you know they were banging you know it
it and
all of a sudden in in this 70 fold up
seats was al pacino
uh john f k jr uh
olympia dukakis raul julia sam
shepard arthur miller uh john malkovich
it was incredible man
and then that that's when everything
started to change because i think
i learned the audience was learning the
industry was learning wow latin content
is valuable latin content is for
everybody let people want to see latin
people and
people definitely want to see themselves
so it was a breakthrough moment
culturally it must have been such a
small venue too where you could
literally see their faces you'd be
looking
to be like hey
nervous sometimes because my sight was
good then
and i could see those faces and
sometimes you know they're not they
they're looking at you but they're
getting tired or sleepy or
whatever i don't know yeah yeah you know
you see all that people yawn sometimes
you know
sometimes i'm glad now that i can't see
because
all the audience looks like they're
really just loving it i'm gonna tell a
random story
from running for president that's like
my parallel and you know like uh
you know it's a little bit later on or
whatnot um but you you have a town hall
in new hampshire and you can see
everyone's face
so so there there's like this like real
like you kind of know if it's going well
or not
it's one reason why you see these
various political figures being like
okay like change it up because you see
what's working what's not working
and then i look out there and then it's
like paul jamadi sitting there and i get
distracted i'm like oh [ __ ] pulled your
bodies
[Laughter]
like part of you i just wanted to stop
and be like hey you know right out of
yours from
you know like what you know whatever
movie i saw you went um
when you see your heroes it's like when
i saw a patina i was like you know i i i
heard myself stammer because
here's your hero watching you perform
it's
it's it's a little too much you know i
mean it's a little too much
well in your case it must have felt like
such an incredible
vindication or nighting where like
they're like kind of letting you in the
club where like
some people who are heroes of yours who
are world-class new york creatives
actually took time out
saw your show and then you get all these
great reviews from the material i can
see why you're like wow
you know like uh like this is working
and you were what 26 at the time is that
right
yeah i was 26 and uh yeah they gave me
the confidence
to keep going and then boom i wrote my
next show spicarama
and uh i won best play of 1992 at
warner hall award and uh
you know those those little wins were
really important to me
because it fueled me you know it fueled
me and then when my show mama mouth hit
hbo
then the latin audience found me and
they would
go everywhere i went chicago san
francisco
texas wherever i would go there was a
huge latin audience
to be had and you know they just made a
church you know it would
be calling response and yelling and
hooting hollering and it became electric
that's beautiful you must have felt so
welcomed by the
uh latino community the whole time
because you
are one of the most prominent voices uh
in my mind in
in the industry and when you got started
there was probably
a massive void or vacuum you were
filling but you know one of the things
it reminds me of a little bit
is i have some folks who are uh
asian-american creatives and whatnot and
and some of them also talked about like
hey
i i only i get cast as the waiter
the gangster like that right right like
whatever
the asian american roles are i know i i
i bd wong is to tell me about those
stories you know
like here's this massively talented
young man
and you know his opportunities are nil
you know
just waiting for that perfect asian role
to come along you know
i love the way um whoopi goldberg did it
like when she hit stardom
she was also a big influence for me
brilliant brilliant performer i saw that
her show that mike nicholls erected on
broadway was life-changing for me
but she had them change white roles and
male roles to make them a black woman
just take
any script and boom she her her recipe
was just making a black woman
and i was like yeah yeah
just make it a black woman that's a
pretty good system you know i think
people are
to this would be like yeah let's just
like big make this yeah
an asian dude right because hollywood
didn't understand
hollywood didn't understand how to write
for a black woman they didn't know
how to create that farm to create
product for her so she said just take a
goddamn
regular [ __ ] script and make it
about a black woman it just
and it worked it worked yeah whoopi and
i became friends over the last number of
months um you know
uh through through the view uh during
the presidential she's been great
um she's awesome she and i got into a
lot of trouble
uh when with al gore was running for
president she and i did the dnc
and both of us had wrong cheap raunchy
material
and and we got the dnc in so much
trouble because both of us for some
reason
decided to go like blue and rogue at the
same time and it was too much
yeah they couldn't handle it people
would call it going going
really funny those are different times
too and
oh yeah and you show up in person to the
dnc uh it was a probably
a very very boring crew because i've
been to these dnc things and
[Laughter]
yeah yeah not exactly a place for edgy
humor
oh no no it was so wrong but i learned i
learned
i never did yeah next i think i did the
john kerry one and i just really toned
it down
that's really funny you were like i'm
just gonna play this one right up the
middle maybe yeah yeah no
it wasn't a place to be raunchy it was
like oh my bad i read the room wrong
i remember when um i was
meant to speak at the the dnc uh
convention this past year and you
actually feel a bit of pressure because
you're like well the ratings for this
are going to be sky high and you know
you were very very tightly controlled in
terms of
time um and and so we had a speech that
we prepared
and then they gave notes and the only
notes they gave john were just trying to
cut words
they're just trying to like make stuff
shorter it's just like whatever it is is
making sure
like substance like they were cool with
the substance yeah yeah and
and then they had me into practice the
the dnc speech which is a weird feeling
because you're like practicing
speaking to the american people and they
also tell you
that hey if there's any technical
difficulty we're just going to play this
recording
so it was like a weird dress rehearsal
where you're like
all right like let me like um
give me my best yeah let me have five
people in the house
as i'm talking to america and then be
prepared to be
cut out yeah yeah like that that's what
it was and then like time
it was like the real one and um it was
it was from a studio in new york in that
case and it was like uh me and cory
booker were in the same studio so
we were um sharing some time and
shooting the [ __ ]
uh how great is he man isn't corey great
i mean he's a great boss he's a great
guy
[Music]
you